oh my god  what what is it I can't believe it  family guy's been canceled again what  the hell oh my god yay finally I don't  have to cover my tattoos or wear this  ridiculous hat and wig for this stupid  prosthetic leg that's right  I'm horizontal I've spent all those  years as a vertical fraud I can't  believe we've been canceled  well apparently Fox has a new president  who wants to go in a different direction  can you believe that idiot where is he  where's that son of a [ __ ] I didn't  believe it when they said they'd have  cheese and crackers for everyone but  they did it ladies and gentlemen the  president of Fox what kind of idiot  would cancel a hit TV show good evening  dad you forgot the other eye there you  go now you're visibly upset you bastard  you won't get away with this you hear me  do you hear me loud and clear  Oh  you